[拍手]
ああああああ
ありがとうございます
唐突ではありますけれどもちょっと皆さんにご質問させていただきます
例えばいうも新するかとぐらいにあっ車いますでしょうか
ありがとうございます
和田ですね子宮外生命体とですね今後交流であったりとか遭遇ということがですね
可能になってくると思われたところへいらっしゃいますでしょうか
ありがとうございます
こちらからは誰が手を挙げて全く見えませんけれど
ポイントレースでちょっと遊歩のことについても送信を跳ねさせていただきたいと思い
ます
デザートいった乳房の話あたりだとか宇宙人の私をですねさせていただく際に
としても日本国内だとですね
会はまたを変えるとか話を手で持ってきたのかとして雪的なものなのかなというふうに
ですね
考えられてしまうのが常こういった you for a てもだったり
10:00 ja キーワードでございます
a
ですがこういったも信じる信じないええという話はですね宗教
ゲームもともですねつながってくるのではないかと私は考えております
私自身ですね士会は日蓮宗のお寺でございまして私自信も映像量でございます
そので中でですねえ常日頃 a 感じるでことがあります
それはですね自分の家が
をも宗教に属していてこの周波なのかということまでですねえ知ってる方は結構
いらっしゃるわけでござい
連日が住み爪でいきますのですねその主曲ですね
内容で当たれたとかナビというものですね
知っているた方ですねかなり少なくなってしまいます
その中で常今少しこういった宗教問題になってきてしまっている部分がですね
6集客ということ
私はですね集そういったものですね氏んじゃない
髪を退けての存在しないというわけですね
言われる肌がいらっしゃるわけでござい
ですがこれもですねやはりそういった太平洋
中身というものですね以外することによってですね神仏の存在っていうので実際ですね
感じることができるわけでございます
我々52教科書としてですね朝はてるのは今日本でございます
奥山中身というのですね実は我々人間にもですね
もうすでに1000生まれた時から集まってもあるはでございます
そういった希望場所がですね我々へ宗教でお子さん a からするとですねえ
生きる術なのか刷毛でございます
そういった中メニューですね私自身も ag 07ですねそれな経験もあるわけで
ございます
まあこの体もの音ですねまったく並行して並べるつもりはありませんけれども
流行であったりとか10人というものもええ
た髪をですねどこまで調査京急は進んでいるのかということですね#エフェクトですね
もしかしたらあ信じていただける mo になってくるのではないかと思っております
実際ですねアメリカああロシアソ連ですねそういった国々ではこういった英雄方の研究
10時の証左と思うんですね進められております
new 方というものはですね磨くに後部大栄たがその後へ無安打といいですね
イメージ目ついておりますけれども実際にですねアメリカ軍15度下で持ち上げており
ます
アメリカ空軍が
ufo についてシャーベた書もずプロジェクトグループというものがございます
そこではですね1万2000件もの融合の目撃情報であったりそういったデータをです
ね色んな
検知科学的な見地からですね
いろんな調査を行ったものがございます
1947年から69年の間にですねそれでも目撃情報があったわけでございます
それを一つずつ a 社目で言ったっていうえし者さんプロジェクトブルームバーグと
いう英語でござい
その事例のですねほとんど解決されている a ことではあるんですけれども実はその
中の700円あまりが未だにですね
未解決なはでございます
これだけへ年数が経っていることにも関わらですねそこの内容が未解決のまま
てほったらかしにされているのがもしかは分かっていてもですねアメリカ
開示していないのかそのあたりは分かりませんけれども
ごーいったものを考えるとですねアメリカ野球 s ね小川研究
が進められている話なのに日本ではですね甘いあまりこういった情報が流通していない
のは事実でございます
a それですね私イシハ原博医師会というところから開きましたけれども
石川県羽咋市ですね実は ufo の街でございます
こちら白衣の駅前でございますけれども
どこに旅行あるかわかりますが皆さん
殺風景な駅前を移しておりますけれどもここにあるわけでございます
ユーゴ融合で魔女向上しましてですね
こういった駅前でも動いた
街全体がですね ufo で a 街を募集している間違い鮭白紙でございます
この動きがですね約30年前から始まっておりましてですねそこにある博物館中学部さ
でございます a コスモアイル羽咋という説明職員を知ります私た可能と申します
ごーいったですねあの融合で絵馬チョコ勝者ですね
色々あるんですけれどもこれで電車もですね氏
もなってですね走っているわけでございます
そもそもですねなぜ
羽咋市がああいう本を交えて町おこしをしたのかというとですね結構皆さんあの
なんていうものは何ですかよく見えるんですかっていうのも言われるんですけどもこれ
がですねちょっとってつけたものではなくてですねしっかりしたアークんまぁして
ちょっにご紹介させていただきたいと思います
午後者県羽咋市30年前ですねまず行われたのか
早食いギネスブックうっていうものでございました
これがですね我々自分のマンションはですね一番を決めてですねそういったものを a
皆さんに公表しようと a したものでございます
皆さんも経験あるかと思います自分のいいとこ
自分の少々ですね話してくださいと言うと a なかなか出てこないものでございます
これあの安静特にも一緒でございまして自分の街の良いところというとですね
うーんて悩まれる方がたくさんいらっしゃいますじゃあ逆にですね駄目だとおっしゃっ
て下さいと言うとですね山ほど出てくるわけください
そういった中でですね白衣のいいところですねぜひ
を知ってそこからいろんな物発見応募なを教え州で作られたのはこの白衣のギネス
ブックというものでございました
1989年のことでございます
まあこの中でですねもちろん a で晴れるものへを
例えば100m 相談だとか
here till よ
いません
それでそんな中で a
このギネスブックを作る中でですね白眉のことをくまなく調べた中で出てきたのは a
自作の絵どちらの文章でございます
受けた声に白衣にはですね桁台者という神社がありますねあの有名でございますけれど
もそこの近くにある歌にですね
ケタ高演技というものがですね上されておりました
水とかアイ部分見ていただきたいんですけれども
上から5文字目あたりからですね非行
北自在神力
ねもしかしたら有効なじゃないのかというところで始まったのは流行で町おこしで
ございます
ブーバですねええーこれはですねあの全然あーし女性ませんけれども
ここでいう方だという日あっでございます
後もうしまさ江戸時代から白衣地石川県羽咋署ですね劉邦でいうことですね講習を行っ
てたわ
家なんじゃないとかということで始まったのが
融合で町おこして流れ
即時ですねまず基礎素振りでございますえーまぁかなり大きなイベントでございます
けれどもこれで恵方に会シンポジウムというものなんですけれども
ここに行くまでの間にもでたくさんのことがありますけれども
一番いうこと町として
全世界ですねシェアしゃべるほどがあったとか線
こちら宇宙という方国際シンポジウムというものでございます
義手寛永という器官ですね設けましてその中でアメリカや旧ソ連の宇宙開発に関わって
いる方々
そういった
研究を行っている方達をですねお読みしてですね
羽咋市で登壇していただいてええ
50開発はもちろんでございますけれども
いう地球外生命体というものについてですね語っていただいたは楽しい50でござい
ます
展示物も a おきますですねいつはこの時ですね
世界に二つしかない触れる尽きぬ子へところですね
nasa が持ってきていただいて展示物ておりますか
その時の持ってき方はですね nasa の職員さんがですねぇー
jal 3ケースに手錠自分に提示をつけてですね持ってくれたっていうんですね凄い
件中な形でもってくれて
だそうでございます
おしぼ重要な花ですねえええ実は宇宙 by はず融合というのがすごく密接に関わっ
ていると話し別で皆さんしていただいたわけでございます
どうしても十分八尾 ufo そういったも同じで必ず分けられてしまいますけれども
アメリカではですねこういったものがすごく
あのー
当時新興のような形でですね進められているのがこういった ufo
てもなぜ炎症でございます
そしてですねこのシンポジウムで ufo の街を者ですねえ土台づくりをしまして
建設されたは私今
を詰めさせていただいております保護コスモアイル羽咋宇宙科学天日でございます
牛ですに手にするものは何かというとですね
方の宇宙船でございます
実はここにありますアメリカのレッド想定を受けと思って実際に打ち上げられた訪問で
ございます
だいたいえーみなさん宇宙学特別だということですね調べて来られるんですけれども
ブリキのおもちゃだと思われる方々カー半数でございます
それで中に入ってですね絵本も乗ったことを知るとですねすごく良い音が割れるから
ません大変多くいらっしゃいます
中にはですねアメリカの93年からお借りしてきたものもございますし実際に使用され
た旧ソ連の宇宙船なんかも展示するわけでございます
これなんかですねえ旧ソ連のものにあ通信制という通信衛星でございます
これもバックアップ木と言われる実際に使用できる本物の女性でございます
こちらはですね外にありました熱湯存在理由と一番上の部分
アメリカのマーケ一優先でございま
もともとはですね icbm と言いましたいれば何度見ざるでございましたので号
いった狭い a 女性がですねアメリカで初めて打ち上げられたわけでございました
英語たですね今学的な宇宙船を持つ博物画縁つくりまして
もともとですね平成8年に英国を買い反しておりますね今22年ヘタっております
けれども
もともとは羽咋市の運営として没まったく入って行ってきましたけれども今現在はです
ね指定管理指定管理者としですね運営をさせていただいております
その中でへ市から委託された時にですねいろんな試みでたくさんて行ってきましたして
間になって英語ですね
なのでちょっと皆さんに一つ司令官になって帰ったものですね少しご紹介させて
いただきます
あまり反応がありませんでしたけれどもこういったですねあのブッシュ氏の
キャラクターを作ったわけでございます名前はですねサンダーくんという名前でござい
ます
石川県にとっている電車ですね七尾線というものがあるんですけども七尾線が電化され
て20周年
8ですね簿備える開眼されます15周年の a ちょうど重なる米都市でございました
そこでですね電車の中で宇宙人あの
を入れたらですね面白い田中ってちょっと意見が上がりますですねぜひ直接メディ
コート者のこういった
キャラものでございますこの10人ですねあーまぁいろんな場面で出てくるんです
けれども
今ですね白紙へすごくあの親しまれてるキャラ300でございますけれども
初めのころですね1ラボさんがですね入ってくるとしてさな子はいたらですね
内定で競ってやってくる世間をあったわけでございます
なのであの親御さんが綺麗ですねあのちょっと子供はなくんで声てくださいって言った
ことですね
あとちょっと不遇なでセーブ中心でございます
ちょっと設定もございまして千葉県にはですね
あの千里浜アート山があるんですけども白衣にですね観光に来てた
50人がですね千里浜に様は成約しましてその a 修理 a 修理ない金を稼ぐため
に a子住まい博でバイトしてるアルバイトの宇宙人という設定でございます
設定定期でしまったりつけてちょっとどうかと思うんですけども私もですねあの
サンダーくん存在を知ってへ来られるお客さんに対象ですね
お兄さん300ですかって言われたこともあるんですけれども
まあそれだけで選曲私も付10時にやられてしまいます
ハグ一緒にはですね大
重要文化財が10校は a 久住十分方が中とあるのでは明星寺というお寺がござい
ます
そこでですね奉納プロレスというものです猫と嗜好のアレたわけでございます
そのイベントいいですねこれ絶対面白いかというえ
気持ちですねちょっとあの宇宙人上げさせてくださいとお願いしてですね今年挙げさせ
ていただいたものでございます
実際に1300プロレスマスクを作って実際のプロレスラーですねこういった形で
22銭上がっていただいたわけでございます
かなりですねあの話がそれたように感じますけれども
a 正能司令官になってからあのなぁ活動してへたくさんのお客さんに喜んで
いただけるようなということはあしているんですけれども
こういったあのちょっとへへ
ハズレでもないことをしてしまってもですねあの家に動いてあるものはですね方もの
挑戦
英祖ものですね爺さんが売りでございます
こういったのさ長く使ってですね色んなイベントをしておりますので
五回もあったことですねあの日本の宇宙開発 jaxa というところはあります
けれどもそこの園児やにエンジニア
頭で政府アンケート書かれたんですね
その場で買われたのはどういったことだと思うと宇宙開発の声た本物の立派な宇宙船と
ですね
ufo と青中中一緒に展示するんだ道なというふうに
別れたわけでございます
は確かに言われてみたら感じるかもしれませんけれども実際ですね
街を交渉していうを用いますですね a シンポジウムのサイン雨がた旧ソ連の会実際
清酒といった宇宙開発に携われる
形がですね
今後そういった ufo 宇宙人というものをですね
科学的に調査研究を進め得ていかなければならないというふうに
c 50分の3にも言われていただけでございます
これがですね今後 a 1私をいたしましょうですね
ぜひとも日本でもそういった研究調査はですねオーナーれるべきだと思っています
それをさせることによって日本の10倍酢もさらにですね発展するのではないかと私は
考えております
こういったですね町おこしをして a
ufo というものをもちましてですね頬の縦線持ってくるという形でございます
けれども何から始まっているかと言うとですね
羽咋市にあったものですねそれを使って ufo これは有用じゃないのかという考察
ももっとでマーチをご紹五訂できているものでございます
30年間ですねこのいう方とキーワードを使って街を交渉して今ではですね
羽咋市のイベントに山岳でてくれないかとか
飲食辺でありますとですね view ボウラー面であったりだとか
スーッという場所ですねさあていただくくらい
ハグ1オール融合ってものですね型着しつつあるわけでございます
その中でこういった融合というものはですね
あまり日本では知られていないことかもしれませんけれども
どういうものはですね町おこしの原因になるか分からないわけでございます
今ですね住んでいる町
誰でしまうとですねえどうしても a 悪いところばかり出てきてしまいますけれども
そういった自分たちへの街前でここはダメだと思っているところがですねもしかしたら
職種のきっかけになる可能性もあるわけでございます
竜王というものですねすごくあの
キャッチーな言葉ではありますけれどもまあ上昇につながるということですね皆さんが
待ち伏せ必ず
すごく有益な支援がですねあると思いますのでぜひとも自分達まぁそうですね良さを
ですね皆さん知っていただきたいと思います
できますですねあの子カフェハグしもでもうしいただきたいと思います
あれございましたん
ああああああ
[拍手]